and just for anybody who's an introvert
i am a terrible introvert i'm so shy
but i want this more than i want to be
shy so i just
you know i'm not an actor but in that
way i am an actor
you know i will i will go do the act and
i'm not always good
you know if i'm in a crowd and i don't
know anybody and i don't have a wingman
that's kryptonite i shut down and i sit
in a corner
to this day i'm ashamed of it but i just
i'm just
powerless but you know i know to have a
wingman i don't have somebody else to
help me
you know or at least find oh i know that
person they can introduce me you know i
mean that's
you know um but you know when i was a
little kid i um
you know i would just my mom would say
you know you want to you want a slurpee
and and she would
you know i'd be sitting in the car and
and she said we have to go in and get it
i would just sit there and cry because i
didn't want to go in
by myself i was so shy